this man who became again the oldest
player at 40 years in 185 days to make
his playoff debut in NFL history they
now 40 year-old and 187 de year old Josh
McCown here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you Josh
I'm doing very rich how you doing man
how does it feel to hear that back two
days later Josh well you know I still I
think you know brings back those
emotions and triggers those things you
know just just very thankful you know
for the opportunity to play and compete
and it's a great game we get to play and
and this journey that I've been on and
wanting to get into the playoffs and all
those things and to be able to go out
and play
obviously circumstances being
unfortunate with losing Carson but um
but to be out there and competing was
was fun and and you know just very very
thankful to have that chance so and the
reason why I that moved me is for
somebody who you know I've been involved
with the NFL for many years and it is a
family it is a family decision certainly
when you play for nine teams I cannot
imagine how many boxes you and your
family of packed or schools that you and
your family have had to find or you and
your family have had to pull kids out of
and and it is it is a true emotional
experience to just get out there and
helmet up and pad up and and that's why
it moved me Josh it certainly did you
know you know I'm used to see my wife
work a tape gun box together in a
heartbeat
but that's that's the reality of this
business that we choose to be in and
it's a it's a it's a great you know it's
a great business but it's also a tough I
mean we're going experience this right
now with with coaches going through
coaching changes and and their families
being uprooted and and and there's a
human side to this for sure that that I
hope you know people remember you know
when they when they watch a game or when
they get ready to scream at the TV or
whatever and and no doubt we are
compensated well
but anybody who's ever have to move or
do anything like that can understand and
it's part of it and and you understand
that and is like I said it's it's part
of what comes along with being a part of
this business and in the privilege of
playing in the league and so you know
all those things kind of hit yet once at
the end of a game like that and and so
certainly felt that this weekend but I
was glad my family was there and the
stands with me my mom and dad and and
wife and kids and and and so I was
thankful that they got to be there and
be a part of it and see it and wish the
game would have gone different obviously
sure but special nonetheless well it's
not your first rodeo obviously as we've
established and answering the bell in
the middle of a game and having to go
out there but this is the first time
it's ever happened in a playoff game
what was going through your temples when
when went clearly needed ahead to a blue
tent on Sunday Josh right yeah it's it's
the nature of kind of these this
quarterback room you know you you sit
there and all you're you're you're
getting close knowing each other working
together trying to find ways to win you
know I had some dark moments sitting
there with our back against the wall you
know and at four and seven and then and
then winning those last games and and
signing away and so seeing everything
that Carson's put into it you're sitting
there and watching him kind of go
through you know trying to get his you
know mine right and feel better and and
and you know waiting to see what the
doctors say and stuff so your heart's
torn you know because you wanted to be
okay because it's it's my friend and
there's a guy that I've watched work
really hard to get to this moment
especially given the the the recent
history and you know in his career and
so so you kept the shift from that mind
to okay I got to go play and I go
they'll be there for my team and I got
to go execute this game plan and so it's
it's a little bit of a dichotomy there
but but but once you know he headed to
the tent I grabbed a helmet took some
practice stamps your mind is okay let's
go play and and you should have focused
what do we have to do to try to win this
game and obviously you don't
at that point in time if the game is
yours for the rest of the day when did
you learn that fact oh right yeah I
think after the after the second series
you know kind of came back and because
usually I in happen earlier this year in
Atlanta where they came and they checked
him I went in he actually came back in
the middle of the drive I went in five
or six plays and then he you know you
know I'm sitting ready to call the next
plant I get a tap on the on the shoulder
in the huddle he's like hey I'm back oh
so I head back the sideline so I kind of
had that my mind like okay maybe he's
gonna be you know come running out any
minute and get me out of this thing but
but you know after a second I think
second series I was in there like it
doesn't like he's coming back so so it's
just you know in your mind is just
celled in at that point okay let's go
the rest away and get this thing done
did you at any point go up to Doug
Peterson say let's do the Philly special
you ever say that to him you know that's
always you know in the in the in the in
the mix I'm sure sure and the
possibility of things to be called and
and I certainly wasn't wasn't afraid to
to take that if we if it came down to
that but you know the way the game
flowed it just it didn't come to that
but but um but yeah you know you never
know well I mean and again through Josh
McCown Eagles quarterback here on the
Rich Eisen show after filling in for
Carson Wentz in the playoff game on
Sunday so do you guys talk about the
clowny hit have you guys talked about it
think about whether that was dirty
out-of-bounds what where do you stand on
your teammates on that subject right now
Josh yeah you know I mean obviously
those things get discussed and and you
know you're talking about 50 soccer room
and and so the opinions are going to
vary unfortunately when you lose a
playoff game and you kind of have the
final media on Monday there's not it's
not like another week of work where you
have this ongoing conversation you know
I've seen the hit a few times and and um
and I I don't I hate assuming that that
people play with ill will or or move
with ill intentions and you know I'd
like to think that guys go out and they
compete as hard as they can and they
play as hard as they can and
unfortunately things happen you know
looking at the hit and and looking at
the angle of his head and and stuff like
that when you see it in slow motion and
from different angles when a big guy's
head gets gets that low to the ground
it's I think you know again those are
things that we're probably trying to
eliminate from the game and so I hope
that moving forward we can we can
continue to focus on that and make the
game safer and you know that would be
that would be my opinion on that but
like I said I hate to assume that
Jadeveon was going with it with an ill
intent but this is a physical game and I
understand that and and you know we we
talk about it on both sides of the coin
as far as playing the game physical and
wanting to and wonder play as hard as
you can and and we you know our
defensive guys are coached to play that
way and you know it so it's it's both
sides and it was unfortunate and again I
don't know it's hard I hope that's not
the case and and more than anything I
hope that the league can continue to
look at that and look at this thing you
know with the with the fine-tooth comb
go through it and make sure that we're
getting these things right so that we we
keep our game as safe as possible do you
think players would be good with the
league adopting what college does which
is even if there were is no flag on the
play like there was not on Sunday with
the clowny head of your of your teammate
that and I and the sky would buzz down
so let's take a look at for targeting
and eject a player through a replay do
you think of the NFL players would be
fine with that well I mean I think over
time like if instances like this keep
popping up where you have such a split
opinion and maybe it's not a split but
you have such a it gets talked about
while you and I are discussing it now if
it's one of these things that it didn't
draw flag and you know what I mean if
this keeps happening we're we're maybe
we're missing some of these things and
we're not getting it right then
absolutely I think then we need to just
just like we've done to introduce on the
medical side a spotter so that so that
we we protect a player and and we should
do that through the through the through
the game play as well because because if
you're going to say that it's post hit
you know we want to protect a player
well let's let's do everything we can to
do it before the incident happens and
and may
having that in there would encourage
that because at the end of the end of
the day they've made it clear they said
they're trying to take you know the head
and and the use of force with the helmet
out of the game they've they've made
that clear and so so if you're going to
do that then do it as best you can and
maybe that's a step that would get that
done Josh McCown here on the Rich Eisen
show so what's next for you oh yeah
we'll see I'm gonna you know I'm gonna
get together with my family and
obviously talk through things like I
said the other day after the game I've
retired once so I know how to do that
but now I don't know if I know how to
stay retired right surly but but we'll
just see I you know we haven't made any
decisions you know I'm looking forward
to spending some time with my family and
and and you know just kind of reflecting
on this year with them I had you know
the time of my life with these guys this
year and this was everything I wanted
you know it was you know as you know
throughout my career in the 19's that
you mentioned earlier most of those
things were start-up situations you know
a new head coach rebuilding young
quarterback whatever it was you know and
so to come into this situation where it
was a good football team that had had
recent success and and a Super Bowl
winning coach and coach Peterson and
this season going the way it did and and
kind of have our backs against the wall
there and and then to be able to pull it
out so I've been on so many other
situations where we didn't run the table
and we talked about it but it happened
and so to be able to do that this year
was special and and and so I've learned
so much it was just a great great
opportunity this year for me and I had
the time of my life so so it's hard
sitting here right now to not want to go
I'm coming back I want to do it again
all those things but I really need to
you know my kids are getting older and
and that time goes fast as well so I
really want to get together with them
and and try to make the best decision I
can't possibly well I know you said in
your postgame press conference that your
body talks to you differently when
you're 40 and you keep talking about how
you're 40 I gotta tell you your hair
looks eight your hair looks like an
eagle it's not real us it's more it's
probably more like 17 18 at 8 I had a
horrible cowlick I've gotten that under
control now
and and and so I feel a little bit
better about it now so we appreciate
though you got to sit with trust me as a
man follically challenged at age 50 I
noticed these things and and and you
know you told our producer at the
beginning while you're on hold that you
you have a photograph of the two of us
from back in the day at the NFL Network
when we met years ago is that the case
yeah we're sitting we're sitting there
in those two club chairs in that first
studio right when you know shoot I was
oh - I believe right it's the room in
micro three or something like that yeah
so right when the network started and no
argument ir and and you you were less
follically challenging this year there's
a lot of low there's a lot of flow
there's a lot is generous there's flow
there for sure and and looking sharp
I really wasn't you know I look back at
that picture and and and learn a lot
about myself too and and my hair game
was not where it needed to be well back
then we could have we could have had the
moment that you and Arnold had in the
preseason a couple years ago where we
ran our hands through her hair at the
same exact time right we could have done
that you know we could definitely could
have had that there could have happened
you you were you were totally capable of
that at that moment and and we could
have made it made it work it was it was
such a fun day that was my like first
time around the studio and anything and
just I remember just watching you do
your thing and and how much you know
when you when you have the earpiece in
and you can hear like what's going on
and how well good you were at that you
know and it was just it was remarkable
and and always have appreciated your
talent for being able to communicate our
game Josh you're a good man I've told
you that all fair through Twitter and
all that sort of stuff and I'll tell it
to you right here man I've enjoyed
watching you all those years and
obviously if you want to keep playing go
for it if not enjoy those kids get back
in the paparazzi game that you were in
before the Eagles called whatever you
want you deserve it I appreciate it rich
thank you right back at you at Josh
McCown 12 follow him on Twitter and
Instagram that's Josh McCown here on the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app